we'll keep taking calls right six one
seven eight three zero four seven five
zero do we have our next caller with us
we do who's on the line with me name in
town is great to start with hey this is
Christian again from Northeast rule over
month what's on your mind today
so dividend Lewis I want to ask you guys
what are your thoughts on the way a
society should value a space program
first ask you one other question base
how long has it been since you listen to
the show I haven't watched any of the
most recent episodes but I watch maybe a
few days ago okay well I just want to
tell you and I say this with utmost
respect peace and love to quote the
great Ringo Starr I don't know if you
know but we announced about seven six
seven weeks ago that Lewis was leaving
the show and he is gone so there is no
Lewis today but if I may I would love to
answer a question did I accidentally see
David Lewis I meant David and Jason okay
got it okay okay so let me deal with the
I'm sorry you know what sometimes I say
Louis to that that's it's happening to
all of us I think that society does not
value space programs nearly enough I
think that it is one of the ways that we
can actually work productively across
these sort of arbitrary country borders
that we know are often the source of a
lot of problems although in many ways in
modern society they are of course
necessary and I'm sort of on we've
interviewed Neil deGrasse Tyson about
this and really NASA spending this type
of spending should really be thought of
as a good investment because number one
but we may need to find another planet
to live on if we keep destroying this
one number two as I mentioned it can
foster a cooperation between countries
and number three in the same way that
we've seen technology that we can use on
earth come from space exploration
technology I would expect that that
would continue to happen so I am very
Pro space exploration type spending
okay uh I don't know I don't know if we
lost him but let's let's move on that is
my answer
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s